hello and welcome once again to Android
design in action as always I'm your host
Roman Nurik hey guys Adam crush and here
in London Nick butcher and today we're
gonna talk about I don't know what are
we going to talk about we're gonna talk
about fitness apps personal fitness apps
actually this is a one of Nick's
favorite categories so he'll be doing
lots and lots of talking today about
endomondo which is one of the great apps
actually the great app that we'll be
highlighting today and then after we
cover fitness apps and specifically
actually some tablet stuff about fitness
apps will jump into modern you eyes and
more specifically some patterns that
that constitute modern you eyes beyond
just what you've seen on the design
guide so with that let's jump in with
endomondo so I'm gonna hand it over
right - oh we've got some flickering
going on
should we try - let's see if we can just
unplug this and plug it back in
hopefully that is channeling the spirit
of the attending from last week yes
still happens is a why caster East oh
yeah we should we restart okay let's
let's restart we'll get back to you in
one second folks
you
all right so I think we're back and
hopefully the hopefully the the
flickering is stopped I think it's a
little bit of the demo gods you know
that haunted the app clinic for so long
giving us a little taste of their
medicine but anyway with endomondo I
guess we should start with Nick since
this is Nick one this is one of your
favorite apps you want to talk about in
the Monday yeah this is one of my most
frequently used apps I would say do a
little bit of trifle on them in my spare
time away from Android development so I
use this application to kind of track my
training and stats nerd about it so if
you've used to fitness outfit office
most the common functionality of like
tracking your workouts using GPS and
logging it and so on and so forth but
one of my favorite aspects is they've
done a really nice job of following the
Android UI guidelines and also
integrating some fun stuff like contact
badges and so on that integrate deeply
with the Android UI so here the ski shop
we're looking at we can see for example
an activity feed and and your local
history of the workouts that you've done
I think you can see they've done a
pretty pretty decent job of following
our you like outlines and you're just
too internet guy this is a very very
pitiful version of history I don't
actually do running or cycling or
anything that's really you know Nick's
line of work there but this is just one
example of like what it could look like
you know after you capture an event what
it looks like but obviously in a real
world scenario you'd see a full list of
things sorry Gornick is a very sparse
list did you have a comment you wanted
to make about the tap to refresh button
listen yeah yeah yes I actually want to
throw it out to you guys like what are
your thoughts on the sort of pull to
refresh or tap to refresh kind of
pattern personally I actually like
seeing the Refresh icon in the action
bar which switches over to it you know
indeterminates you know while the
Refresh is going but I don't know what
do you guys think so he just explained
the pattern as is if it's not clear from
the screenshot it's kind of a variation
on the pull-to-refresh pattern so here
the say
the right you can see Romans activity
would actually be flush to the top until
you pull it down and then it reveals an
extra options interpreter refraction so
in my opinion is this isn't working
terribly well because pull-to-refresh I
guess has some convenience it's just one
gesture whereas this is like a gesture
than its app so you may as well just
have the refresh button for me I prefer
like you say Adam the refresh button in
the action bar which turns into an inter
similar progress
mostly because in Android and lists
aren't springy like I can see this is a
pattern from from Tweety on iOS and it
works pretty well on that platform
because each list has this kind of
springy characteristic to it so it you
know it works really well to overextend
it to kind of do something but it's
Android you don't have the expectation
is to have some kind of force field blow
or you know it's some kind of indication
you've reached the end of the list so
there to prevent reveal an extra option
doesn't fit with the mental model for me
yeah I definitely agree I think that you
know if you use something like taps or I
guess pull-to-refresh really our
recommendation has been if you use it
then you know use it in addition to
something like a refresh button in the
action bar or even in the overflow if
refresh is automatic or if it's
something that users aren't really going
to use all the time then putting it into
the overflow is totally acceptable and I
think in this case there's plenty of
room to show an actual action item there
you know sometimes it may not be
possibly have to put in the overflow
menu so maybe you know pull-to-refresh
might be more obvious to users then I
guess but you know in this case I
personally would think it'd be a good
addition sorry okay so you push all this
so this these two screens are the
history and kind of the Activity Stream
in the newsfeed if we go ahead to next
there so some of the core functionality
it has which I really like is the
ability to find routes so kind of routes
that other users have created which is
awesome if you're traveling so if I come
out to California and visit the Mountain
View mothership I've used this
functionality to find running groups in
a you know an unfamiliar area which is
fantastic you means let's all route
there
I'm pretty sure I mean really just
taking yeah and as well as kind of just
seen the reach itself you can have this
concept of a champion you know so on you
can try pizza when it's time or that
kind of stuff or fun stuff so these are
these are fun features we wanted to put
out and highlight from the phone app so
as Roman said I'm a heavy use of the app
and a couple times down on me so I've
been pretty happy of using the
application but what I really feel like
it's lacking is some tablet features so
if we look at what the functionality of
the application offers on the website
there's actually some really really
useful functionality which I feel would
be perfect to pull into the the tablet
application so here for example this is
a kind of the base workout screen in
which you can use to track your workouts
and I find this really motivating
because you get this like a month view
which shows tiny little avatars of the
the activity you've done and for me it's
kind of this is one of the things that
keeps me coming back and keeps me using
the application like if I miss a couple
of days and there's no way you can come
back and fill in those squares I love it
when you browse back and you see like a
fully populated month and see you know
how kind of consistent your trainings
being Europe you're a workout a holic
just looking at this I mean more than
one item of exercise per day that's kind
of impressive well I kind of commute to
work on my bike which is kind of
cheating people there we go yeah and
yeah so I think this is a really
important piece of information which I
thought would be you know super handy to
kind of pull out on the larger real
estate that you get on their tablet and
going on to the next screen I think the
other thing we wanted to talk about was
some stats that you can pull out like I
said okay the stats know I'd say I love
the answer pour over my workouts and
seeing you know am i improving have I
done more mileage if I don't you know
faster average times all that stuff so I
feel like there's a real opportunity to
pull out some of this information when
you have more worry like when we talk
about four tablets no one's suggesting
the único running with a nexus 10 straps
to your arm or your back
that's ridiculous maybe mix in seven
though even the Nexus Emmett every to
put up a good point actually I hadn't
really considered it's kind of sat in a
gym maybe any kind of on an exercise
bike for example so you're using your
tablet to watch a movie or catch up on
the latest Android development on that
but you might want to be able to kind of
think over to a tablet optimized
interface on your workout that to
capture you know that awesome workout
you've just done mmm-hmm but for me I
think the biggest thing is I want to be
able to do is kind of consume the
newsfeed see how I'm doing
pour over my stats and also plan ahead
like look at the different groups that
are available so this is the kind of the
major aspects that we've tried to
incorporate into a reimagining of the
application and one thing I want to just
point out there's this really small part
of this website I guess in one of the
panes on the side that shows you I guess
you're the the individual I guess the
types of workouts that you've done as
well as for how long you did them this
month as well as how many calories
you've burned I feel like that kind of
summary information is is fairly
interesting to see on a month-to-month
basis so having that readily available I
think also be something that's that's
interesting in in a tablet or a larger
screen Eli if you move on I think
there's there's one more oh no we don't
okay so we took a look at endomondo and
actually I talked to Nick about how he
uses the app and you know what he would
want from the tablet experience and we
took a look at what it could look like
on a tablet and specifically more of a
consumption experience providing more
like a consumption flow you know like
you're sitting on your couch and you're
planning what to do for you know the
rest of the week or you kind of want to
just see what your current stats are as
well as you know like like Nick said if
you you know happen to arrive in in
Mountain View visiting you know the
mothership I guess you know what what
are the nearby routes and how to browse
them in a very visual way so we we took
a bunch of these things and we decided
you know let's create something that's
like a really nice dashboard and not a
dashboard in the sense that it's just
kind of just showing you navigational
options
like the dashboard pattern where you'd
see like four six icons that would show
no piece of content this is really like
a Content forward dashboard that shows
you different aspects of the app just
different aspects of the service all in
one screen so we focused on I guess the
the primary the information hierarchy
here is really like you know your
current workouts that's the primary pane
here it's the center pane and then
second I guess the second most important
item on the screen is is the social
activity you know whether somebody
commented on one of your you know one of
your events or if somebody posted you
know that they've just ran like near
route near you or route near you against
you know you want to see these things in
a nice easy to consume feed and the
right and what we've done is we've
basically taken the existing feed from
those handset screens and we've kind of
enriched the the individual content
items so each piece of content here
you'll notice has you know more than
just a piece of text it has the time it
has you know clickable objects like you
can you can touch on Han to see you know
details on Han like a full profile page
for Han and then if it's if it's a route
that you may be interested in maybe you
expand the route into this kind of like
a token or a content expand of that
that's in there the other thing I wanted
to point out is that to take action I
think in the in the previous or in the
current app on handsets you can comment
on something there's this kind of
comment button next to each list item
but there's no way to like anything I
think liking is kind of a or plus
wanting or such it's kind of like at a
lighter weight way to interact to say oh
yeah this is this is great you know
congratulations
so just offering commenting versus
liking seemed seems kind of yeah so
nothing has actually okay it's no inside
ey because he likes like a plus in a
comment bubble but yeah if you click
that it gives you the option to like oh
yeah so what we did here is instead we
use the different different affordance
basically the the overflow affordance to
indicate that hey there are actions
there are multiple actions you can take
on this and obviously you can you know
long press to you should be able to long
press to select to take action like like
multiple posts but here to take action
on a single item you can either long
press to show the contextual action bar
or just touch this you know the this
overflow to show that there are multiple
items or multiple actions there and this
is very similar to what Google now does
so in Google now you have a bunch of
cards to look at settings for a card or
to take action on cards along with
action buttons at the bottom you can
actually see this overflow next to each
card and then lastly we've we've done
this kind of unique presentation of
nearby routes so we've looked at you
know what you know let's say this app
has information about you know the top
three or four routes near you that you
haven't you know start or favorited this
is kind of like a content a method of
bubbling up content it's got a content
discovery mechanism so you'd be able to
you know swipe left and right between
the different different nearby routes
showing a little bit of data about you
know how long they are
what percentage of users like them and
then what's the the best time on that
this is all data that's already
accessible in the APIs version so this
is this is a 10-inch landscape you'll
actually there's one thing in this on
the left here you have this kind of
summary information like this month
these are the activities you've done
this is how many calories you've burned
this is how much time you spent working
out anything else you want to add Nick
that a controversial use of the bold and
light patent there's a being a little
bit of a love it or hate it on their
need for pointy lockscreen yeah there's
actually a combination of condensed here
so there's condensed and light I believe
there's bold light and condensed
versions of Roboto so there's lots of
typography going on throughout these
marks so yeah my general feeling is I
love it like I really like the free
major sections you've broken up into two
when you have a 10-inch UI a 10-inch
tablet with you know space enough to
display this thing so you kind of get
this instant view of what's going on you
get these free major topics that I'm
really interested in looking at from
from the first thing I mean I'd love to
be able to tap through some of these
statistics on the left and I can imagine
seeing some of those graphs which a
failure on the website being available
on the device as well that'd be
wonderful but then yeah I think they've
kind of you've done a nice job of like
bubbling up the things I really care
about and it's important to note that
like these this dashboard is very
interactive its content forward and the
content is manipulable right so if you
want to touch into snowboarding to see
you know all the different stats for
your snowboarding for this month you can
do that you should be able to touch that
i'm the other thing i'll mention is that
you know this app had more than just
these three sections so what i've done
here is i've offered a an action bar
spinner to to show you other parts of
the app so if you want to jump into like
other sections for example not
necessarily not the settings because
that should be in the action overflow
but maybe like i don't know if you
actually want to start capturing you
know data on a tablet maybe that's
that's something that you should be able
to do from us but yeah i think it's very
important to stress that then this is
the same application as we just saw on
the phone right i think it's completely
okay to have a completely different you
know dashboard completely different home
screen when you're running an entire
different context i mean it's the same
information that we're going to present
through the application it's just a
completely different like visual
treatment or priority as it were
so let's in the interest of time let's
skip through a few of these other
screens so this is basically the
portrait version and what we've done is
we've we've really tried to think what
is this screen look like on multiple in
multiple orientations as well as on
multiple sizes I mean it's it's not just
a 10-inch landscape tablet world out
there you know there's portrait devices
there are seven inch devices and they're
probably gonna you know vary in size and
screen resolution so this is just an
example of what a 10-inch portrait
mock-up can look like well basically
done is we've taken a linear approach to
to laying out this content so the
hierarchy is still maintained the very
top most item is the most important
thing your calendar the second item the
second row in the screen is this
horizontally palpable social feed and
the presentation here I'll admit that
it's it's not really refined there's
definitely a lot of work to be done here
but I mean there's just one way you can
you can start to think about this and
then that nearby routes section at the
bottom is still there so it's it's kind
of taking up the same amount of space as
it normally would but again these all
these sections are fairly flexible you
know you can potentially actually let me
just talk about that in a bit
let's look at the the seven-inch layout
and this is where I wanted to mention
that you know that top section at
calendar it's flexible you can
potentially show another row of days at
the bottom or the top in this case
you're seeing another row from February
and then you can you can scroll it you
should be able to scroll up and down to
change the the current month and then
you can rearrange the content from the
left to the bottom this the summary
section and the most important part of
the screen I guess is that you know on a
7-inch Gy you don't necessarily have all
that space as you do on a 10-inch UI so
one of the things you can do for these
dashboard type screens is to switch over
into tabs and they should be
horizontally swipeable so you know since
there's no real horizontal interaction
here it should be fairly straightforward
to you know allow us wiping on the
entire screen contents to switch between
your workouts your newsfeed and
and your rounds and those should all be
laid out vertically I just want to call
it as well that it's absolutely fine
like to use this margin point I really
like the way you've done that in the
seven-inch landscape for example some
people feel like you have to absolutely
fill every inch of space on the screen
that's just not the case I mean if you
know you couldn't stretch this calendar
to be so much wider it would start to
feel you know at the wrong aspect ratio
to feel then gamely and it's absolutely
fine to introduce a margin point here
and to skip enough room for it to
breathe yeah it's it's definitely a
little more comfortable and a lot of
tablet.you eyes to have some extra
breathing room on the sides I forgot who
it was that mentioned this there was oh
there's a great post too talked about
this it is specifically around
typography especially when you're laying
out tight it's not only about you know
the measure the amount of words per line
or characters per line but it really
eases the strain on the eye to have nice
generous padding when you have lots of
you know heavy content especially text
so you know don't be afraid of too much
space worry more about too little space
I think that too little spaces is more
dangerous yeah and also where the space
is on the screen like you don't have
things on the outer edges of the screen
like some list views which might
automatically stretch out from a phone
you are yeah you definitely wanna have a
great kind of distribution you want to
stand back from the screen and be able
to see kind of a nice mosaic of content
not just you know stuff thrown into the
left edge yeah have a squint at it and
see where the weight of the the content
lies mm-hmm all right so I think that
was it for and oh no nevermind we have
some lockscreen markups from Nick Nick
they want to talk about the LOX cream on
cups yeah this is my number one request
and among the guys please make this I
love but it needs this looks mean
widgets are finally here and I think
this is like a perfect use case right so
we just quickly mocked up what it could
look like so here I am out on a run and
right there were my sweaty hands I don't
have to unlock the device just to see
how fast I'm going how far I've travel
or you know tactic
so I've smoked up here just showing
three of the major piece of information
when they have the kind of the collapse
view of the rock screen widget just tell
me my distance pace and total time and
then if you were to swipe down to kind
of expand out the lockscreen widget you
would get the following view like new
you can take action as well so you can
pause stop or resume maturity chords the
workout straight from here see you don't
have to kind of like you know you're out
of breath quickly trying to stop stop
the time so that you know you don't miss
miss your PV or whatever so I think this
is a really really fun and use case for
lock screen widgets and just to point
out I really like what you've done here
Nick with the use of white so I mean
you'll notice here that everything is
either white a shade of white or I guess
a transparent white or transparent
entirely and the reason we can do this
is that you know since you're on the
lockscreen
it always dims the background so even if
the background was pure white the
dimming would actually make any white
text or iconography on top of the
lockscreen still very much legible so
you definitely have the opportunity to
use you know single color you know
monochrome icons and UI elements on the
screen and I really like what you've
done with you know taking the the play
in the stop buttons from the app which
if you look at the app they're actually
green and they're stylized and taking
that and adapting it to what the lock
screen looks like which is really just
you know white on transparent yeah it
can be scary as the designers you didn't
have any control over these as wallpaper
obviously so you don't know the backdrop
so yeah exactly that I didn't want to
have you know some crazy clashing color
if you're gonna have a green button it
wouldn't really work so I just went for
a very clean way to cover and think it's
about 45% of busted black over the top
of the wallpaper to dim it down to
achieve this awesome okay and this is
just the last screen is what it would
look like if you're actually you know I
guess in the paused state or upon the
regime state yes it gives you the option
to pose in
okay so with that let's jump into we've
about seven minutes left unfortunately
well maybe sub fortunately or
unfortunately we don't really have much
or zero design news today so we'll just
talk about some UI patterns that are
beyond just you know the ones you've
seen in the design guide so you guys are
already you know we've been you know
talking about action bars and responsive
design and using typography a lot so you
guys have been probably fairly well
exposed to these types of UI patterns
especially you know horizontal swipe
swipe to dismiss we did some you know
some mock-ups in weeks past that
included those UI is UI patterns so
let's look at some of the less commonly
known patterns and these aren't
necessarily official patterns but these
are kind of they're really just you know
community patterns things that the
community have been have been using and
you know things that we we think that
modern he was should definitely take
advantage of if it makes sense a by
community we mean the incredibly
productive mister Nurik has made most of
these so you're very humble but thank
you well so that certain gourmet
community so the the code behind these
I've definitely written up a bunch of
the kind of code snippets to show how to
implement this but they're really
following some of the design practices
from from Android apps front from I
guess first party apps from system apps
as well as from the community so but yes
we do have code samples for all these so
if you have questions on how do you
actually get to implement these then let
us know after the show so first let's
talk about done and discard we featured
this in the past basically it removes
the action bar entirely and replaces it
with a very similar looking done and
discard bar
so you know in really simple like in
simple screens where you're just you
know editing you know a form like
filling out some simple information
we're making some changes to a contact
for example you know you could have like
save and cancel and up and back
but what you know one of the
alternatives is really to just show this
very simple straightforward done and
discard or done and cancel a bar at the
top I guess do you guys have any other
comments on this I mean it's we've
talked about in the past but yeah I like
it it looks it's completely unambiguous
as to what's gonna happen right yeah you
can I feel it stays true to kind of what
the action bar offers but this visual
treatment just makes it super clear
what's gonna happen yeah there's an
alternative where the done button
appears in the top left and then discard
is something like in the action overflow
and that's more useful if you have other
actions that you want to show besides
just done discard them and cancel or if
you really don't expect or don't want
people to cancel like if it's like if
you're saving a contact chances already
in it you know make it make the change
yeah I think that means that's a good
point for example take a look at I think
in the system and the people out looking
at something about creating a contact
and I think also the same that I created
calendar event right in the examples of
this yeah I was just gonna say that that
other form sort of makes them more
obvious what say getting the back but I
might do like it would obviously save
the content yeah in that case okay so
done in this card that's one we
recommend this for kind of again simple
editing forms you know the screens that
you're really just editing a piece of
content maybe not something that's
terribly complex then pinning progress
and this is something that I'll very
briefly cover because it's it's kind of
less often used and ideally you know you
save everything to your device you know
you cache everything and cache
opportunistically but you know in cases
of you know where you have movies or
large files where it's clear that the
action of caching or saving to your
device is pretty heavyweight you may
want to give the user an explicit way to
you know to save or to to pin content
from the cloud on to your device and so
this is this is basically a little UI
element this little pin button is kind
of like a checkbox where you know if
it's check then this should be pinned
and then in the background it shows the
progress of the pinning so if it's like
a 300 Meg download and you've you know
the app is downloaded you know two
hundred Meg's then you know this should
this pie chart should be you know
somewhere about two-thirds of the way
full so very very simple little UI
widget that you can use throughout your
apps if you're if you're dealing with
very very heavy content pulled from the
cloud so I've been a settlement as well
because M it discouraged some people go
down and it kind of really explicit
route of saying I'm I in offline mode am
I in kind of online mode where under the
stream or and I think that's the wrong
way to go really I think you should
really have a single UI and then just
hence the user whether or not you know
it's available offline and picking up
and following the cues that the Play
Store and music app which comes on most
devices use is a good way to represent
them okay so we had about two minutes
left let's fly through something that
some of these others does anybody want
to talk about undo bars or or inline
undo who wants to do it I feel you know
I feel like Nick likes this one better
yeah yet so and there's a great section
in the design guidelines talking about
when to prompt for confirmation and when
to kind of offer and do and so I'd work
through that flow chart but the sense of
essence is that you're kind of prompting
for confirmation for everything is kind
of like a roadblock and you can't really
perform any actions very quickly so
preference to that is if you have a way
to recover then to offer this kind of
undo action so yeah as the name it kind
of like implies you know this offers a
way to recover from an operation you
just don't like archiving an email that
you undo to restore it back into your
inbox and as Adam says this works I feel
really really well with in conjunction
with the swipe to dismiss pattern where
when you swipe an item answer that list
say it gets replaced with an inline kind
of undo button which lets you kind of
like bring it back in from the side I
think that works really really nicely
take a look at their latest version of
the Gmail app on Android 4.2 for example
of that
you know I think if anyone's actually
use one of these you breathe a big sigh
of relief like I deleted something I
don't know where it went and then
tapping on do it quickly bring it back
is a great experience
mm-hmm okay mm-hmm let's uh let's go to
the next the next pattern and we this is
a pattern I guess we've Nick and myself
we've dubbed this quick return there's
no real official name for it but the
idea is that you know there's this this
is Google now is a screenshot Google now
this is the idea that you know you want
to have something that's persistent
that's always available something like
in Google now like the search bar but
you don't necessarily want to take up
some of the you know the precious
vertical real estate so what you can do
is you know that bar can scroll off the
top of the screen as you start scrolling
down but as the user starts scrolling up
ever so you know slightly that bar
wherever you may be in the scroll area
that bar slowly starts inching back and
then as you kind of start scrolling
further the bar becomes fully visible
and it's it's almost it almost gives the
impression that it's floating above the
rest of the content whether you know by
using a drop shadow or whatever it's
really kind of pinned to the top without
actually always being on screen so it's
ready readily available but not always
visible it's kind of this nice duality
there let's jump to another UI pattern
this is tokenized text fields and I
realize we're running a little short in
time so we got to fly through this but
idea here is that you know rather than
typing you know typing out email
addresses and you know dealing with lots
of freeform text that you know be smart
about it and if you see something that
is a piece of rich content like it
actually resolves to some object
you know replace it in the text field so
the user can interact with it like it's
an a real object and not just a bunch of
characters of text I'm gonna have sky
guys I think that was the I know we have
one more the last one is bezel swipe
this is Nick's favorite favorite UI
pattern basically we have horizontally
scrollable or interactive content in the
core layout of your screens
you know you can you obviously can't
really use that for switching between
tabs or or exposing things like side
drawers or navigation drawers so the
idea here is that use the the bezel the
the leftmost and rightmost about 16 dips
of the screen where if you initiate your
swipe from there it's treated as a bezel
swipe so you're almost like kind of
pulling the content from off the edge
this is what chrome does Chrome and
definitely actually this is one of the
new lockscreen this as well
as far as I know so yeah so there's
another great pattern for for always
making a horizontal content accessible
using swipe but also having pan
horizontal interaction within your
screens I think that's the last one so
we're a little over on time but um I
guess thanks again for joining us on
Android design in action as always I'm
Roman see you guys Adam Kosh and Nick
butcher who just left us from women yeah
so we'll see you not next week but
probably in a few weeks so see you guys
you guys have a great break